[Musique]
bonjour bonjour maïté je vois devant
nous des choses intéressantes et je me
demande quelle curieuse idée vous avez à
nous proposer
et bien aujourd'hui on va faire des
homards à la mayonnaise d'avocats et le
périnée d'avocats à la sauce d'aubin
je croyais que vous étiez dire à la
mayonnaise de homard et je me demandais
ce que voulait non c'est bien pas du
tout ou est-ce que vous avez été
chercher cette idée a été chercher ça
donne ce côté là bas tahiti sous le
globe voilà il ne faut pas oublier que
c'est un territoire français aussi la
polynésie tahiti d'acteurs dont nous
sommes en france en parlant de cette
recette on va essayer de l'adapter à ce
que nous pouvons faire de ce côté ci du
globe
avec ce vol un autre maïté cette idée
c'est un ami qui me l'a donné en fait
qui a un restaurant là bas oui s'appelle
je crois le pacifique parce que nous n'y
avons pas été malheureusement vous le
plein de bonnes idées il a bien fait
parce que l'on va ici il s'appelle jean
gallopin est justement ce qui est bien
c'est qu'il explique avec quel produit
on le fait à tahiti mais comment on peut
essayer de le reconduire dans les
services notamment avec les mêmes
saveurs mais ça ressemble à la portée de
recettes qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
eh bien il nous faut de l'armagnac il
nous faut des avocats bien entendu et
cela ils sont superbes
il nous faut des feuilles de gélatine on
m'expliquera après pourquoi tout ça fait
bizarre
il nous faut des oeufs ouais mais vous
inquiétez pas ça va être bon quand même
après le faux de l'aïe ne faut des
tomates la leçon reçue permet aussi de
jolies comme eto'o il faut du terrain de
lauriers il faut d'aci boulette il faut
des heures l'avis des avocats on l'a dit
kursaal environ à vos doigts et là il
nous faut de super bowl on les a là on
peut faire à moins mais refaire cela ils
sont magnifiques bien vivant les puits à
la douala parce que vous avez évolué
éviter faudra résister c'est omar sont
superbes et voilà et avec tout ça on va
essayer de faire cette superbe recettes
et par quoi faut-il commencer on va
cuire les homards vous préparez assumait
pour ça ah oui comme d'habitude avec des
parents de poissons des parures de
poissons de carotte d'un paul girot
fusain blanc de blanc ce qu'il faut
alors on pu le remarquer puis la
complète ce contact là rouiba c'est
relativement facile mais dont la mort
est instantané c'est ne souffre pas
et voilà et là il faut attendre qu'ils
deviennent rouges tout simplement tout
simplement
alors ça nous laisse le temps de faire
quoi maintenant on va faire la
mayonnaise d'avocats vous les bonnes et
bien si on a bien sûr qu'est ce qu'ils
sont de la pure et dure quand même non
voilà j'en ai vu qui magnifique non bon
ensuite les couper en deux et évidemment
sans abîmer le noyau on va essayer de
garder le noyau parce que le noyau je
vais m'en servir après c'est pas non
j'ai non mais je vais le mettre dans un
pot oui et ça va me faire des de verdure
à pousser une plante qui est superbe
il a pour ce chien alors à vous tous
pour voir s'il ya besoin d'avocat comme
ça dans un pot une belle plante voilà ça
vient de commencer à le passer oui moi
je vais me monter ma crème sel en soit
je crois mais simplement voilà j'ai mal
agi mais la faute est un tout petit peu
c'est pour ça qu'on va faire cette
mayonnaise mesure de passer d'avenir ça
va ça passe oui et vous ça monte ça va
avec
vous avez déjà maintenant visualiser
parti pour de tourner ça sort oui oui la
nouvelle tout mélanger voulez j'ai un
peu à mélanger le reste et on met là
dedans et vous allez mélanger tout ça
on avait mis à 12 ou au choix pour vous
faire une espèce de novices peuvent
avoir à saisonniers ou sinon regardez ça
c'est voilà d'averse est d'amasser
beaucoup mais alors là je vais rajouter
un petit peu le maigre la création avait
dit dès lors ça donne un goût plus
simple c'est joli ça soit beau c'est bon
c'est vrai il faut arrêter de golan
alors un petit peu de vinaigre au puit
venus aux coups de cuiller à peu près
par beaucoup et et du sel du sel parce
que ses fans c'est quand même un petit
peu
wavre up et voilà et il nous reste plus
maintenant il faudrait aller voir où en
sont nos âmes en ont marre qu'ils sont
puis juste après jour dit ça alors voilà
les homards sont rouges beaux ils sont
beaux ils sont bien cuits sûrement voilà
je vais ressortir et attention à ne pas
vous brûler parisans parce qu'ils sont
jeunes si oui voilà
alors je vais le coupé en deux tous quel
sens dans la longueur par le travers
malheureuse
superbe la tête de même oui là dont
alors vous allez me donner assiette
superbe et circuits comme il faut oui ou
si jolie on serait tous dedans que ça
tapait 10 là on va bien l'arranger
la hausse est jolie la leur aussi qu'il
va falloir mettre alors notre dame et la
lyonnaise d'avocats et vous savez que
cet excellent parce que j'ai goûté et ça
ressemble à du beurre alors il s'est
réparti mills il vous offre ces
délicieux s'en servent comme beurre à la
main mais ça ne m'étonne pas parce que
c'est à se mettre à genoux puis sur par
uche encore le rayon pour réduire la
marge je ne vous suis pas vous pouvez y
aller
allez-y non surtout c'est délicieux
surtout très très très bon quoi maïté
ces compétitions
c'est très fier oui vous pouvez c'est
joli et il nous reste quand même une
autre recette à faire maintenant
oui on va faire la perrine intérim
d'avocats perrine avocat que faites-vous
pour commencer alors je vais m'occuper
du lait vous en faites quoi de ce lac à
quesques gens que je vais faire je vais
le mettre là comme ça ils reprennent les
gîtes à peu près au même voilà comme ça
je vais y mettre les feuilles de
gélatine toi vous avez faites tremper au
préalable alors on a droit de tout lier
un tout petit peu que ça se déroule bien
il ya les laisser bouillir en
surveillant on va le laisser bouillir
tout doucement
et pendant que ça bouillonne gentiment
on va s'occuper des avocats nous les
avons peut les couper en deux vous avez
enlevé les noyaux vous allez garder pour
votre jardin vous appelle et vous vous
allez lâchez et moi je m'occupe des
oeufs
très bien je les passe à la maline air
célèbre géniteur voilà on va finir je
vais les mélanger allons les unes
garnier je ne vois rien d'autre que je
sais comment parler au lieu d'être sucre
et b il ya de la gélatine et puis voilà
que ça prenne un petit peu mieux
protéines
rinne passe très bien les avocats ça va
être joli joli couleurs tissus perdre un
peu vous avez là cette plaine à vous
mettre dans un saladier
oui ça fait un peu plus près à la voilà
vous voulez tout dire un petit peu le
mélange et oui je vais lui mettre un
petit peu de crème fraîche la remet ça
gâche arriérés
vous allez sans doute comme une crème
anglaise c'est à dire que vous allez
mettre dans le lait qui est rageant mais
pas vraiment bouillant ne peuvent pas
venir donner sur les réseaux sur le feu
ça se prépare ça fait aux lettres on a
fait tout ça y est c'est tout à fait moi
j aimais parfait et moi aussi
on a regardé connais bien joli très bien
c'est du bel et bien on va finir c'est à
dire je lui du sel et du piment
d'espelette ou wayne efforts là on a
intérêt à pas ce déchet les doigts après
une fois qu'on sera fait ça parce que
nous l'avons bâtie en fin mai un petit
peu sade 2-2 petit bilan de la crème au
diable l'avarice et de la crème
et puis mes oeufs la gélatine et le lait
là vous allez mélanger tous à imaginer
jeu toy
vous allez me faire un petit tapis là
avec quelques tranches de quelques
branches on n'a pas refait et au milieu
voilà regardez-moi ça si c'est joli
voilà la plus jeune rihanna plat parce
que quand ils sont jolis temps se
déroulera le jour voilà j'aurai bien
vous allez recouvrir et moi je vais vous
en couper pendant ce temps quelques unes
de plus claire de nous avoir besoin
ouais on va tapissé tous ces bons voilà
vous devez recommencer à l'ergomètre un
drame c'est vrai un peu plus fine et
parce que oui non mais j'ai fait la
preuve cela j'allais leur couper les
autres communes non regardez moi ça
c'est vous qu'on va remettre une couche
ensuite il faut garder ça j'imagine
offrez un certain deux heures de temps
aux banques de ne pas les manger parce
qu'il faut que ça prenne alors il ajouté
ça va bien me prendre nous n'aurons plus
qu'à faire la sauce paul amar et dieu
sait si ça va être joli vent vous allez
faire revenir des échalotes et puis vous
avez mis quoi les voilà le con j'ai tu
dis là les têtes de home à électrons
concept et des longs les mais là avec la
sauce tomate et puis du fumé et du vin
blanc et ça fait une surprise avec lui
aussi diplômé à l'armagnac bien d'autres
ces flambées à l'armagnac et j'ai mis
dans les palettes pour bien le relever
prenant la frise faut combien de fois
des jeunes ont laissé aux délicieux
voilà alors maintenant je vais passer
tout ça aux chinois là ça fait rien
parfait on appelle la sauce avec des
écrevisses on a fait avec le quinté de
son écoute beaucoup de choses là et on
passe et tout ça ça va aller avec votre
terrine délicieux ça va être très très
bon mélange des deux mains et et je
trouverais l'on a fait des très joli
plat la comece veulent une inspiration
de polynésie dont bien sûr les amis des
plats d'été comme des terrines d'été
mais alors ça c'est délicieux alaïa les
deux à maar la wii avec c'est un maillot
non avec sa mayonnaise qui est fait sur
gvt moi c'est super la terrine des
moules et oui pas mal les pas rater un
hiver elle est très bien aussi
et puis la sauce ou a marre qu'on va
laisser refroidir comme avant bien
manger et qui accompagnera ces
délicieuses temps regardez moi ça c'est
ce joli et bien voilà un peu de
nouveauté il a bien fait 12 ans restera
sept et parce que c'est
excellent une aspiration de la polynésie
française c'est notre pays quand même
alors au revoir à bientôt et bonjour à
nos amis de la france du pacifique
voilà merci beaucoup à bientôt
[Musique]